The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM:
In This lecture, I
would like to demonstrate
the effects of sampling
and aliasing, and also, some of
the properties of discrete time
linear systems.
What we'll be using
to demonstrate
this is a programmable digital
filter, which is contained
in this box,
programmable in the sense
that many of the parameters
of the filter-- for example,
the filter coefficients, the
coefficient and arithmetic word
length, the sampling rate
etc, are easily changed.
In other words, programmable.
So this is the basic
digital filter.
And then, of course, we have
some associated equipment
to help us with
the demonstration.
Well, we'll be returning to this
filter in a few minutes, when,
together with my colleagues,
Mike Portnoff and Dave Harris,
I'll be demonstrating
several of the ideas
that we're about to talk about.
But first of all, let me
explain what the basic setup is.
The programmable digital
filter consists, essentially
of a system which is a sampler,
a continuous time, or C
to D converter, which converts
an impulse train to a sequence,
a digital filter to
obtain a filtered output
sequence, a "discrete
time to time" converter
to convert the sequence
back to an impulse train,
and finally a D-sampling or
smoothing low-pass filter.
So at this point, we have
a continuous time input.
At this point, we have a
continuous time impulse train,
at this point, a sequence,
then a sequence here,
an impulse train, and back
to a smooth, continuous time
function.
For the first part
of the demonstration,
what I would like to
focus on is just simply
the effects of
sampling and aliasing.
And so for the first
part, I'll just
simply choose this
digital filter
to be an identity system.
In other words, the impulse
response of this system
is just simply an impulse.
In that case, this
overall system
collapses to a somewhat
simpler system,
as I have on this
next viewgraph where
we convert from a continuous
time input to a sequence
and then back to the
continuous time input.
And, in fact, we could really
collapse the A to D or C
to D converter and
D to A converter
together since we're simply
converting from an impulse
train to a sequence and then
back to the same impulse train.
To see what the
effect of this system
is in both the time domain
and frequency domain,
we can look at the associated
time waveforms and spectra.
On the left-hand side, we have
the associated time wave forms
and sequences.
On the right-hand side, the
associated Fourier transforms.
So we can think of an input
continuous time function, which
is of some general form, with
a band-limited spectrum--
band-limited from minus
omega c to plus omega c.
When we sample this
to obtain the impulse
train with a sampling
period of capital T
the associated spectrum is
then a periodic replication
of this band-limited spectrum.
So we have the Fourier
transform of x of a of t.
Then the same thing
reproduce that multiples
of 2 pi over capital T
When we then convert
this to a sequence, that
implies a frequency
normalization,
a normalization of the frequency
axis, so that this periodicity
gets converted to a
periodicity with a period of 2
pi in the digital frequency
variable small omega.
Otherwise, the general shape
of the Fourier transform
stays the same.
We then go back through
the system, converting.
Back to an impulse
train and then finally,
by low-pass
filtering, we extract
just the one replication of
the original Fourier transform.
And what we would recover
is x of a of j omega.
We would recover
this exactly provided
that the bandwidth is
small enough compared
with the sampling frequency.
If, on the other hand, omega
sub c is too large in relation
to the sampling frequency,
then what we end up with
is an interaction between
these two pieces of the Fourier
transform.
And that interaction is what's
referred to as aliasing.
The effect aliasing
is most easily
understood in terms of
a simple example, namely
a sinusoidal input.
So let's consider,
specifically, what
happens with the spectra in
the case of a sinusoidal input.
Here, we have an
input cosine omega 0t,
an assumed sampling rate of
2 pi over capital T. This
then is the Fourier transform
of this sinusoid or cosine.
After sampling, that is just
simply periodically repeated
with a period equal to
the sampling frequency.
And we see that if omega 0, the
input frequency is low enough,
then the original spectrum,
or Fourier transform,
falls within the passband
of the low-pass filter.
This dashed line corresponds
to the frequency response,
an ideal frequency
response, associated
with the D-sampling
low-pass filter.
And, of course, if the spectral
fall, as I've shown in here,
then there is no aliasing.
In other words, what we
recover at the output
of the low-pass
filter is just simply
the original Fourier
transform, or equivalently,
the original signal.
Now, let's consider,
on the other hand,
the effect of increasing
omega 0, the input frequency,
and we can think in
particular of what
the effect is on each one of
these impulses in the Fourier
transform.
As omega 0 increases, this
impulse moves to the right,
this impulse moves to the left.
And likewise, in the
periodic replications,
this impulse moves
down in frequency.
This impulse moves
up in frequency, etc.
Now, if omega sub s minus omega
0 is greater than omega 0,
then these two impulses
haven't crossed.
However, if omega sub s minus
omega 0 is less than omega 0,
then the situation
that we have is
what I've illustrated here,
where now, the impulses that
lie in the passband
of the filter
are at the frequency
omega sub s minus omega 0
rather than at the
frequency omega 0.
So as we think of increasing
the input frequency, what
happens for a while, is
that the output frequency
will correspondingly increase.
But after we've increased
omega 0 past this point,
then the output of
the low-pass filter
will decrease in
frequency because it's
taken on the alias of a new
frequency or a new sinusoid.
And so the output,
in, that case is
cosine omega sub
s minus omega 0.
And there's a
little t over here.
There is-- I want to
demonstrate this effect.
There is another
effect that we'll
observe in the process
of demonstrating
this, because of the fact that
in any real-world situation,
in fact, this
low-pass filter is not
going to be an ideal low-pass
filter, as I've shown here
but in fact, is going
to have some transition
with associated with it.
And so as omega 0 and
omega sub s minus omega 0
get very close in frequency,
in essence, both of them
are having some influence on
the output because of the fact
that there isn't infinite
attenuation of one
of the impulses an exact
replication of the other.
So what we'll see
in that case, as we
get an input frequency which
is close to half the sampling
frequency, will see, in addition
to the effective aliasing
that we want to
demonstrate, we'll
see an effect
which, essentially,
is a beating phenomenon.
So let's move over
to the digital filter
and demonstrate these effects,
where I remind you now
that this filter, the
digital filter aspect of it,
is just simply an identity
system so that it corresponds
to sampling, and then
simply sampling and low-pass
filtering.
What we have as an input, if
we look at the oscilloscope,
is on the upper trace, the input
sinusoid, on the lower trace,
the output sinusoid.
And as we see it right
now, the input sinusoid
has chosen to be low enough
frequency so that, in fact,
there is no aliasing.
Well, let's now increase
the input frequency.
And what we'll observe is
that the output frequency
increases likewise.
The output frequency is still
equal to the input frequency.
We're now getting
into the vicinity
of half the sampling
frequency so
that what we're beginning
to see now in the output
is not just a sinusoidal output.
But in fact, what we see
are the two components.
In other words, we see the
beating effect due to the fact
that the low-pass filter is
not an ideal low-pass filter.
Now what we want to observe as
we sweep past half the sampling
frequency is the aliasing
effect-- in other words,
the fact that the
output sinusoid
will decrease in frequency.
Let's first sweep
back down to DC.
So the output sinusoid
follows the input sinusoid.
And then we'll sweep
automatically from 0
up to the sampling frequency.
And let's see that.
So on the bottom trace
is the output sinusoid.
The top trace is
the input sinusoid.
Were now in the vicinity of
half the sampling frequency.
We're now past half
the sampling frequency.
And you see that the output
is decreasing in frequency
while the input was increasing.
Let's finally look
at that again.
But this time, let's also
listen to the output sinusoid.
And what you'll hear, in
addition to observing this
on the bottom
trace of the scope,
is the fact that the
output frequency first
increases, and then decreases,
even though the input frequency
is continuing to increase.
So let's do that again.
But now, in this case,
let's listen to the output.
[SOUND WAVES RISE AND LOWER]
OK, now what we would
now like to consider
is the effect of
actually carrying out
some digital
filtering in-between
the sampling and D-sampling.
And so let me return
to the basic system
again where we had previously
removed this digital filter.
And now, what we
want to consider
is the effect of the overall
system, when we, in fact,
insert an interesting,
or a more interesting,
digital filter in the middle.
The digital filter that
we're going to insert
is a low-pass filter.
And the impulse response
of the low-pass filter,
or the unit sample response
is, as I've shown up here.
And it's a symmetric
unit sample response.
And consequently, it corresponds
to a linear phase filter.
The associated
frequency response
I show down here, where this
is now the filter passband.
This is the filter stop band.
And, of course,
there is some ripple.
There is an infinite
attenuation in the stopband.
And I remind you of the
fact that, of course,
the digital filter frequency
response must, by necessity, be
periodic with a period of 2 pi.
The cutoff frequency associated
with the particular filter
that we want to
demonstrate is pi over 5,
or one tenth of 2 pi.
And the factor one
tenth is a factor
that I'll want to
refer to again shortly.
Now, the overall
system, of course,
is a continuous time system.
In other words, we have
a continuous time input.
We have a continuous
time output.
And the question
then is, what is
the equivalent continuous
time system in relation
to the digital filter
frequency response
that we have illustrated here?
In other words, what is the
equivalent frequency response
of the corresponding
continuous time system?
We can answer that
by simply referring
to the basic definition
of frequency response
for the continuous time
case and frequency response
for the discrete time case.
In the continuous time case, for
a linear time invariant filter,
the frequency
response is defined
as the gain change applied
to a complex exponential.
So if we consider a complex
exponential as the input,
then the output of the system
is a complex exponential
at the same complex frequency,
but with an amplitude,
which is equal to the frequency
response of the system
at that frequency.
Likewise, for a
discrete time system,
we can consider a
complex exponential input
at a frequency small omega.
And the output is a
complex exponential
at the same complex frequency,
with an amplitude change,
which is the frequency
response of the digital filter,
or discrete time filter, again
evaluated at that frequency.
Well, simply from
these definitions,
we can trace our way
through the system
and see fairly easily what
the equivalent analog,
or continuous time filter
frequency, response is.
Let's consider the
overall system.
And let's choose an input,
which is a complex exponential.
And we'll choose the complex
exponential carefully
to avoid aliasing.
We then sample this
complex exponential
and convert that to a sequence.
And the sequence
values are there
for e to the j omega
and capital T. Well,
this is just the
discrete time complex
exponential with a frequency of
capital omega times capital T.
So the output of
the digital filter
is a complex exponential with
the same complex frequency,
capital omega times capital
T, with an amplitude,
which is the frequency response
of this filter evaluated
at the frequency of the input--
In other words, evaluated at
capital omega times capital T.
Then we convert that
back to an impulse train,
and finally, low-pass filter.
And the output of
the low-pass filter
then has the same amplitude,
but now multiplying
a continuous time
complex exponential
at the original input frequency.
So simply from the
definition comparing this
to the input from the definition
of the continuous time
frequency response, the
continuous time frequency
response is equal to this term.
In other words, it's
the frequency response
of the digital filter, but with
a rescaling of the frequency
axis--
in other words, with
the digital frequency
variable small omega replaced by
capital omega times capital T.
The consequence of that for the
particular digital filter that
we're talking about-- or, in
fact, for any digital filter--
is that the
continuous time filter
frequency response has the same
shape as the digital filter
frequency response, but has
a rescaled frequency axis--
rescaled according
to this scaling.
And in essence, what the
rescaling corresponds
to-- and I think you can
verify this on your own--
is to reconvert or rescale the
frequency 2 pi in small omega
to the sampling
frequency in large omega.
And the upshot of
all of this, is
that this cutoff frequency,
which in a digital filter
is a pi over 5, is now rescaled
to pi over 5 capital T.
And what we would observe
is that as capital T,
the sampling period
changes, then
the bandwidth, or
the cutoff frequency,
of the continuous time
filter changes also.
So let me remind you of the
fact that the digital filter had
a cutoff frequency
which was 1/10 of 2 pi.
2 pi gets rescaled to
the sampling frequency
in the continuous time domain.
And the filter cutoff
frequency will then
get rescaled to one tenth of
the filter sampling frequency.
Let's illustrate
some of these effects
with the digital filter.
What we have, as I said was,
is a low pass filter impulse
response and frequency response.
First let's look at
the impulse response
of the filter of the overall
system-- in other words,
after the D-sampling
low-pass filter.
What we see here is the impulse
response of the overall system.
And we observe, for one thing,
that it's a symmetrical impulse
response-- in other words,
corresponds to a linear phase
filter.
We can also look at
the impulse response
before the D-sampling
low-pass filter.
Lets take out that the
D-sampling low-pass
filter slowly.
And what we observe is
basically the output
of the digital-to-analog
converter, which,
of course, is a staircase or
boxcar function, not an impulse
train.
In the real world, the output
of a [? D-day ?] converter
generally is a boxcar
type of function.
We can put the D sampling
filter back in now.
And notice that the effect
of the D-sampling filter is
basically to smooth out the
rough edges in the boxcar
output from the [?
D-day ?] converter.
All right, now what
we'd like to demonstrate
is the actual frequency response
of the overall continuous time
filter.
And we can do that by
sweeping the system
with a sinusoidal input.
And what we expect
to see, of course,
is as the sinusoidal
input frequency gets
past the effective
cutoff frequency,
then the output sinusoid
is greatly attenuated.
Let's now sweep the
filter frequency response.
And there is the filter
cutoff frequency.
We can demonstrate the
filter characteristics
in several other ways.
One way is to choose, as a
display, instead of the output
as a function of time, we can
display the output sinusoid
as a function of frequency.
And so we'll observe that
on the left-hand scope,
while on the
right-hand scope, we'll
have the same trace
that we just saw, namely
two traces the upper trace
as the input sinusoid,
the lower trace as
the output sinusoid.
And in addition to observing
the frequency response,
let's also listen to
the output sinusoid
and observe the
attenuation in the output
as we go from the filter
passband to the filter
stopband.
Again, a 20-kilohertz
sampling rate and a sweep
range from 0 to 10 kilohertz.
[SOUND WAVES RISE]
Now, of course we're
in the filter stopband.
Now, if we increase the sweep
range from 10 kilohertz to 20
kilohertz so that the sweep
range is equal to the sampling
frequency, in essence,
that corresponds
to sweeping out the digital
filter from 0 to 2 pi.
And in that case,
we'll begin to see
some of the periodicity in
the digital filter frequency
response.
So let's do that now with
a 20-kilohertz sampling
rate and a sweep range
of 0 to 20 kilohertz.
[SOUND WAVES RISE AND FALL]
Now we come near 2 pi, we
get back into the passband,
and finally, back to a
0- to 10-kilohertz sweep
so they were again, sweeping
only from 0 to pi with regard
to the digital filter.
[SOUND WAVES RISE]
OK, now, what we would
like to demonstrate
is the effect of changing
the sampling frequency.
And we know that the sampling--
that the effective filter
cutoff frequency is tied
to the sampling frequency,
and for this particular
filter, corresponds
to a tenth of the
sampling frequency.
Consequently, if we double
the sampling frequency,
we should double the effective
filter passband width
or double the filter
cutoff frequency.
And so let's do that now.
Again, a 0 to 10
kilohertz sweep range,
but a 40-kilohertz
sampling frequency.
[SOUND WAVES RISE]
And we should observe that the
filter cutoff frequency has now
doubled out to 4 kilohertz.
Now let's begin to decrease
the filter sampling frequency.
So from 40, let's change
the sampling frequency
to 20 kilohertz.
And we should see the cutoff
frequency cut in half.
[SOUND WAVES RISE]
Now we can go even further.
We can cut the sampling
frequency down to 10 kilohertz.
And remember that the sweep
range is 0 to 10 kilohertz.
So now we'll be
sweeping from 0 to 2 pi.
[SOUND WAVES RISE]
So as we get close to 2 pi,
we'll see the passband again.
[SOUND WAVES FALL]
And now, let's cut down the
sampling frequency even further
to 5 kilohertz.
[SOUND WAVES RISE]
Here we are at 2 pi.
And then at 4 pi.
[SOUND WAVES FALL]
Now finally, let's
demonstrate this effect
of changing the
effective filter cutoff
frequency by changing the
sampling rate by carrying out
some low-pass filtering
on some live audio.
And we'll demonstrate this
by listening to the audio,
and also, observing the audio
on on a single trace, namely,
the time waveform.
And we'll begin it with a
sampling frequency of 40
kilohertz, change that then to
20 kilohertz, 10 kilohertz, 5,
and then 2 and 1/2,
corresponding to a filter
cutoff frequency then of 4
kilohertz, then 2 kilohertz,
then 1 kilohertz,
then 500, , 250 etc.
So let's begin 40 kilohertz.
And then we'll
work our way down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now, let's reduce that to
a 20-kilohertz frequency
or a 2-kilohertz filter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And 10 kilohertz
sampling frequency.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And finally, a 5-kilohertz
sampling frequency
corresponding to make 500-cycle
equivalent analog filter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, now let's
finally conclude
by returning to a little
higher quality ragtime
by changing the sampling
rates back to 40 kilohertz.
[MUSIC PLAYING]